all right it's been a solid week for me
on Instagram of course I'm on Instagram
at David Pakman there's two themes that
seem to do well on my Instagram account
and those are when I'm cooking stuff and
pictures of my dad's dog and we'll deal
with the dog a little bit later
endearingly known as adderall dog too
many people who watch the show and I'll
deal with that in a second so yes I've
had a little more time lately I've been
back in the kitchen and this picture of
me I guess it's people will criticize
anything Pat in this picture as you can
see I'm preparing to cook a great chili
and I'm attempting to sharpen the chef's
knife that I'm using and there were two
or three comments as well as the picture
did people saying David I don't know why
you're sharpening the knife like that
that is not how you sharpen a knife I
thought you were supposed to keep the
knife steady for safety and only move
the sharpener I just thought that people
may not trust you to to have a knife
like that a weapon like that oh it was a
more general comment like why am I even
allowed to have sharp knives yeah that's
a fair question actually okay so that
doing really well and also the most
popular picture of the week from my
Instagram account this is me in a selfie
with my dad's dog this is Nemo and I
referred to him as adderall dog the
other day because if you don't have food
this dog could not care less what you
asked him to do or what's going on let's
keep that picture up not if we can but
in order to achieve this I had to take
out what is equivalent to adderall for
the dog which is food and I was holding
off in my in my left hand I was holding
a very very small piece one of those
pallets that dogs dogs just loved those
pellets you know they seem horrific but
yeah the dogs love the pellets and I was
able to get him to stay still so that I
could take the picture so check it out
people love adderal dog Nemo the dog
Nemo Pakman as I refer to him David
Pakman on Instagram quite a dog right
Pat means quite a character he does seem
quite well behaved in that picture you
succeeded only only if there's food
involved and I guess that's common with
with English labs from people are saying
on the internet a lot of tremendously
trustworthy people told me that